EXPLOSION.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
I AM SHANNON BREAM IN FOR
BRET BAIER.
NO WARNING FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAYS HE’S PERFECTLY WILLING
TO LET THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
AGAIN IF HIS BORDER SECURITY
PLANS ARE NOT ACCEPTED.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
CLOCK TICKING DOWN TO THE
MARCH 5 DEADLINE TO GET
SOMETHING DONE ON THE DREAMERS
AND THE GOVERNMENT SET TO RUN
OUT OF MONEY AGAIN ON THURSDAY
EVENING, THE PRESIDENT APPEARED
TO ROLL THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER INTO A THREAT THAT
SEEMED TO TAKE EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON BY SURPRISE.
CHAIRING A MEETING ON STRATEGY
TO CONFRONT MS-13,
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREW A BOMB
INTO TALKS ON THE BUDGET DEAL,
SAYING IF HE CAN’T GET AN
AGREEMENT ON IMMIGRATION REFORM,
HE’S HAPPY TO HAVE ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
>> I WOULD SHUT IT DOWN OVER
THIS ISSUE.
IF WE DON’T STRAIGHTEN OUT OUR
BORDER, WE DON’T HAVE A COUNTRY.
WITHOUT BORDERS, WE DON’T HAVE A
COUNTRY.
SO WHAT I SHUT IT DOWN OVER THIS
ISSUE, YES.
I CAN’T SPEAK FOR OUR GREAT
REPRESENTATIVES HERE BUT I HAVE
A FEELING THEY MAY AGREE WITH
ME.
>> THE THREAT CAME STRAIGHT ON
THE LEFT FIELD.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT INSISTING A DACA DEAL BE
IN PLACE BEFORE MOVING AHEAD
WITH THE BUDGET BUT ON THE IDEA
OF ANOTHER SHUTDOWN, THE
PRESIDENT FOUND HIMSELF AN ARMY
OF 1.
>> SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
WE HAD ONE TRUMP SHUTDOWN.
NOBODY WANTS ANOTHER, MAYBE
EXCEPT HIM.
>> WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN KELLY WARNED DEMOCRATS TIME
IS RUNNING OUT TO GET A DEAL ON
DACA AND IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS NOT LIKELY
TO EXTEND THE DEADLINE PASSED
MARCH 5 DESPITE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IN DAVOS 12 DAYS.
>> WE WILL GET IT TO.
WE NEED A LITTLE MORE TIME, WE
WILL TAKE A LITTLE MORE TIME.
I WANT TO GET THE PROBLEM SOLVED
CORRECTLY.
>> KELLY RAISED EYEBROWS WHEN HE
TOOK A SHOT AT DACA ELIGIBLE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVEN’T
SIGNED UP FOR THE PROGRAM.
>> THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN 690
AND 1.8 MILLION, THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE TOO AFRAID TO SIGN UP,
OTHERS WOULD SAY TOO LAZY.
>> AT THE BRIEFING TODAY, PRESS
SECRETARY HAD DEFLECTOR SHIELDS
ON.
>> WE WANT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
ON DACA AND WE WANT TO SOLVE THE
BORDER SECURITY ISSUE.
WE WANT TO END CHAIN MIGRATION,
WANT TO END THE VISA LOTTERY
SYSTEM.
WE DON’T WANT TO KICK THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE SOLUTION.
I THINK IF ANYBODY IS LAZY, IT’S
PROBABLY DEMOCRATS WHO AREN’T
SHOWING UP TO WORK AND AREN’T
GETTING TO THE TABLE TO MAKE A
DEAL.
>> BEHIND THE SCENES, THE
WHITE HOUSE BEGAN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THE NEWLY RECEIVED
DEMOCRATIC MEMO ON FISA ABUSES.
ITS AUTHOR, DEMOCRATIC RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, SAID HE’S CONCERNED
WITH WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE MAY DO
WITH IT.
>> I AM MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THEM MAKING POLITICAL REACTIONS,
NOT REDUCTIONS TO PROTECT
SOURCES OR METHODS WHICH WE’VE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND FBI TO DO BUT REDUCTIONS TO
REMOVE INFORMATION THAT
UNFAVORABLE TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THE
MEMO CONTAINS REFERENCES THAT GO
TO SOURCES AND METHODS THAT WILL
LIKELY NEED TO BE REDACTED.
REPUBLICANS SUSPECT THEIR
INCLUSION WAS INTENTIONAL.
TO FORCE THE WHITE HOUSE TO MAKE
CHANGES THAT DEMOCRATS COULD
LATER CLAIM SHOWED A DOUBLE
STANDARD, SINCE THE WHITE HOUSE
MADE NO CHANGES TO THE
REPUBLICAN MEMO.
THE WHITE HOUSE INSISTS THE
PROCESS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO
WILL BE IDENTICAL TO THAT OF THE
REPUBLICAN DOCUMENT.
>> HE MET WITH THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
WITHIN THE LAST HOUR TO DISCUSS
SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE TWO MEMOS.
WE ARE UNDERGOING THE EXACT SAME
PROCESS THAT WE DID WITH THE
PREVIOUS MEMO IN WHICH IT WILL
GO THROUGH A FULL AND THOROUGH
LEGAL AND NATIONAL SECURITY
REVIEW.
>> ADAM SCHIFF HAS ALREADY LAID
DOWN A MARKER INSISTING ANY
POLITICAL REDUCTIONS WHICH WERE
NOTHING MORE THAN WHITE HOUSE
STONEWALLING, FORCING HIM TO